now I never told that story still are
you sure
you sure you never told him you sure you
never told me Mom you sure you never
told me yeah
you've never told him
I swear maybe I should tell it you
reckon maybe I should tell it basically
[Music]
right guys the time is now our second
half of our Log Cabin tour is coming up
very very very soon those tickets are
sold out but you need to get your hands
on the after party tickets three
locations are Bristol sir
okay okay then on the 9th of September
that's a Saturday is we're gonna be in
the academy oh that's in Manchester okay
North so that one is next door to the
venue of the show Facts so it's gonna be
show and then straight to the after
party Cha-Cha Slide R.I.P straight yeah
all right straight into the Academy of
Manchester bro
last but not least we're gonna turn it
up in a 0-1-2 on Rams ends brommy hey
I'm gonna be at the Mill the mill
Thursday 14th is the show after party
straight afterwards make sure you guys
are there the tickets will be in our bio
in the link make sure you cop them one
more time for the people in the back
we've got Bristol pam pam seventh Manny
the academy knife Birmingham the mill
14th let's go let's go you've been
warned you've been warned it's episode
313. it is everybody from the 313 put
your gosh darn hands up and follow me
gang signs everybody from the 313 put
your gosh down hands up
notice that this man did not have his
hands up
guys with another Banger at 313 as Jimmy
kindly said and you know as we do as per
usual I go straight into the IG question
and this might be one of my favorites
this actually might be one of my
favorites not gonna lie and the question
was what are you pretending not to know
oh first one where she lives
why are you pretending not to know where
she lives damn yeah okay uh next my
sneaky link who I'm in love with has of
his ex on his PC
not even phone PC
got some hidden folders
pretending not to know yeah that's
brutal it's brutal it is brutal my mum
is cheating on my dad with his brother
that's always a thing in it is it I just
feel like I've heard it before
that that can't run I can't find that
out of course no one can find that I
can't find that I keep stuff
I don't know who I'm telling I'm not
telling anyone and a Vex about it
yes yes yeah because it's all your fault
now the first person you tell is all
your fault yeah 100 Matt next one now my
colleague's husband is on Tinder asking
for hardcore bondage with randoms that's
what she gets for heating up fishing
office microwave
bandage with randoms how did she know
that because clearly matched she's on
Tinder seeing that she matched up yeah
she clears it was just in his bio yeah
maybe some I don't know that's extreme
for the buyer but I would be extreme for
Bio but I guess he doesn't want to waste
time Fair straight to the point yeah if
I was married and I've just got like a
secret Tinder account I don't want to
waste time with you I need to I need
this one too yeah it's what I'm into
surely there's there's bad apps and
things that you can use for that kind of
stuff probably anyway uh next the fact
that both my mum and dad have slept with
my sister's friends
hmm
you heard what I said bro both mum and
dad have slept with my sister's friends
are some freaks
since his friends are some freaks it's
crazy bro
damn crazy bro their daughter's
brethrens that's crazy bro
that is crazy that's one of the craziest
things I've heard yep
both parents have banged my sister's
friends
wow yeah that's scary wow because who do
you look up to in your life who's a role
model in your life nobody anymore
everyone's out for themselves no one
cares about the surname anymore
that my dead sister's ex is coming to
the funeral with his sighting
is that it's that snow that's sweet oh
yeah yeah obviously this is mate I'm
assuming it's his main now oh now yeah
due to unforeseen circumstances imagine
getting promoted under those
circumstances bro
wifey's six feet under your seat yeah
now wife is officially charged yeah yeah
and you're up yeah and she's like Fair
yeah Fair any any holes or gold kind of
situations Peak it's Peak next one that
my boyfriend still keeps pictures of
naked women on his phone I'll be leaving
him this year
like relying financially outside who
knows bro she said I'll be leaving him
this year yeah she's lying
she's lying bro my man's cheating on me
I know exactly who the girl is that he's
too good to leave though
[Music]
I know exactly who the girl is but the
pipe's too good pipe is just crazy so if
I have to share it I'll share share it
is caring
I have to
because I ain't night like this before I
can be told that about my dick
guys have a certain level of ego that
they shouldn't be told stuff like that I
had night like this before I can't share
I can't leave man I can't leave I
promise you now a girl couldn't tell me
that
I even know who she is yeah but that
thing I'm don't worry I'm not leaving
I'm not going anywhere
but that'll be the day I'll mess up I'm
not in like four seconds that day
because I'm too the information's too
much for me yeah information overload
yeah yeah then she just gets dressed and
walks out facts packs of bags and walks
out yeah she's had enough now yeah wow
all right what are you pretending not to
know my uncle's other family they'll
find out at the funeral
wow my uncle stole 200 Euros from my nan
the day she became a widow
I found this stuff is too much bro my
boss gave my ex-wife HIV
wait
I heard HIV and ignored everything prior
my boss gave my ex-wife HIV
and he's pretending he doesn't know that
oh my God
oh my God yeah yeah
that my mum is sneaking married men in
our house whilst we sleep
laughs
yo oh my days
whilst we sleep my mom is sneaking in
married men how do you know
the years I've done you Dill oh dude bro
oh sorry oh my God who do I look up to
bro again with the question no role
models that my best friend is pregnant
by our other friend's boyfriend
that's a treacherous Circle
um this is all cheats and lies all
cheats all lies my dad has a newborn
baby he's almost 60. oh for [__] sake
bro I'm gonna be Knack fam I remember
when I was in school this is when I went
to school in Luton in year seven there
was one prayer in year 10 yeah his
I saw him I saw him on road of his dad
one day yeah
his dad was old brother I remember
seeing him thinking oh someone's like
that's his dad as soon as soon as I walk
past I didn't think anything of it my
boy was like that's his dad
yeah that's impossible he's like no he's
his dad bro dad was like old old wow
he must have money because young young
cheeks oh yeah for sure of course
because no one's pretty if they're age
mates yeah yeah age mates yeah doesn't
come from yeah yeah yeah
it's impossible it's impossible she
can't when you say man's frail if
they're age mates she's not pushing that
out
she's not gonna see conceiving it yeah
facts yeah oh wow oh the age mate some
of the words that come to your brains
are so unique sometimes Pro if they're
age mates
it's more used in a context like if um
let's say for example
um I've asked my dad oh I say this is
like more back in the day than now
obviously let's say I'm a teenager and I
say oh wagon pops and try to spot him he
was like you look at me like am I your
age mate do you know what I mean yeah am
I your age mate don't spawn me something
like that it's such a typical African
thing bro oh I love African bars but the
funniest thing I've heard there's two
jokes I've got a few more oh yeah what
are you pretending not to know English
when people start asking me for
directions
it's not fair I'll just help Neighbors
in it are we neighbors are we not
that is hilarious can you imagine asking
someone like bro I'm sorry to ask but
can you find it yeah do you know how to
get to Saint pancreas Matt just says no
hablo espanol
sorry he woke up with that anyway
brother are you here
out also is England it's not blue
English I don't give a [__]
guess what guys
espanol in Spanish I don't give a [__]
laugh at me because you think I'm gonna
ask to edit it
get your ass out now
age mates and I'm the white waste man
[__] you people wear this as well
no one cares about
oh I hate when you're my embarrassing it
so funny
all right why are you pretending to know
why are you pretending not to know
apparently Spanish
all right I've got a female female
the password to my man's phone I don't
want him to change it
hey she's one-uptim I guess
I don't want him to change it how does
she know it
she must have just clocked me
that's why we that's why we do face ID
out here
that's why we only do face ID
that my uncle's child is actually my
father's
damn
my dad lies about every [__] thing he
said he makes 180 pounds an hour
oh [__] that's funny oh that made me
cough oh that's hilarious oh God all
right last couple yeah yeah that I went
through his phone last night and saw his
meeting up with Daisy today guess I am
too
tough
what is the gaming you got clocked tough
these elaborate
um
caught you just tell me yeah yeah yeah
just text we're not meeting yes yeah
we're not meeting Daisy together and
causing a scene yeah
if you if you caught me just tell me
just let me know yeah just text me and
say I know you're meeting Daisy today
you won't see me when you get home go
[__] yourself yeah
I mean yeah I'm sorry I've lost the love
of my life and that's just the game
we're playing
let's not meet Daisy together
because it's just gonna be ugly it's
long for everyone and like what if we
have to walk off in the same direction
oh my God and why do I have to like
explain things to Daisy like it's not
Daisy's it's not Daisy's fault yeah why
do we have to ruin Daisy's day yeah
that's hilarious
all right last but not least
um what are you pretending not to know
person I'm sleeping with wishes I was
someone else
how the hell do you know that no idea
how the hell do you know that
that
psychological trauma that's the horrible
psychological warfare that's what that
is that's exactly what it is oh but yeah
welcome to show guys
welcome guys welcome back thank you very
much for joining us
um
yeah there's a big gold thing in the
middle of us pause and we don't need to
ask you for nothing anymore facts you
did you did your dude you did you do
deal you did you act your acts of
service so we thank you for that
however if you want to do a little bit
more head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs it's going to cost
you literally an
insignificant three pound amount of
Tempe a day so run the P to SMG and join
the cult babies for real for real for
life for life but for life is over here
we are we were day one is over here we
are and you get respect from the daddies
when you're over there if you're not you
get nothing
so anyway head on over to patreon guys
and binge all the episodes that we've
done over there almost four years worth
almost four years worth catch us every
Thursday over there uh join the Discord
Channel and that's fine
bro it's one someone said it's the most
popular patreon channel in the world
and I could have made that up but you'll
have to sign up and find out thanks
so anyway guys
um obviously subscribe to the channel if
you're watching leave us a nice review
if you're listening without any further
Ado if you're kissing in it's time for
top five top five top five top five this
week is
drum roll please
the most followed artist on Spotify
most followed artists on Spotify Fair
interesting I'll give you from 10 to 6
before I give you top five I'm awful
like pop culture I don't know what's in
what's [__] who's new sound like my
dad honestly I'm terrible I'm just
terrible dad walk in yeah but I'm
terrible it's trendy yeah yeah I was
terrible what the kids are talking about
yeah
laughs
cool
uh Jimmy sends you unlocked first can I
have your top five please right I've
gone for the weekend Bad Bunny Drake
Taylor Swift yeah t swizzy and Beyonce
remsky I want the exact same as Jane
Winnie apart from
instead of Drake I've got Michael
Jackson
uh Ellis
cool so I've got Drake Beyonce
Taylor Swift
I've got an essential sea
he's coming up um
and then Dave
and Dave as well which yeah cool
probably I feel like [__] Harry
Styles is probably [__] in there as
well
he's doing a madness he was I was it was
Beyonce or Harry Styles I'm Vex if he's
in there just for context Harry Styles
is 43. oh thank God okay cool calm we
can get on with that
so number 10.
with
69.02 million followers the weekend fox
say
it's an elf charged it
when is this when is this list from this
is as of August 2023 really I swear I
saw a post like last month saying the
weekend is now the most followed artist
on Spotify number nine with 72.36 Bad
Bunny it's just pointless bad money baby
now this is going to come out and win
this uh number seven number eight sorry
was 73.7 M's Justin Bieber
Forgot by him number seven with 74.6 M's
Eminem oh interesting that's very
interesting that is interesting
uh number six with
77.9 M's Drake
oh god listen I was gonna say this now
it's in the top five you've got mandem
who are singing nursery rhymes I bet
it's cocoa melon yeah
I know I was letting you after you said
it three times I've never above
correcting you livid anyway
and you're reading it yeah I know my my
my dyslexia was doing numbers with the
letters it doesn't make sense but it's
doing numbers with the letters bro oh
um number five now we're at the top five
of 81.6 million T swizzy okay cool
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift and you said
Taylor Swift as well damn
um
number four I think she only got one
more in the race number four you do
number four with 83.94 uh Billy eilish
Billy eilish would have been a good show
honestly no one wrote Billy eilish ah
number three with 85.19 is RG Singh
which is an Indian okay
um composer singer bro these Indians are
crushing it you know the number one
YouTube channel in the world is not even
Mr Beast you know
yeah I think I've seen it before uh
anyway number two with 92.53 M's Ariana
Grande I was gonna write Ariana Grande
that's pissed me off I was gonna write
Ariana Grande
and I'm not surprised by that you
surprised by Ariana Grande yeah because
like what has she done lately yeah I've
not seen a lot of her stuff like she's
like anything lately but I'm quite
surprised yeah I was literally gonna
write around now that's pissed me off go
on number one with a hundred and
basically 114 million followers
Ed Sheeran ah that would have been a
sick so
um [__] for context Beyonce is number
31. that's crazy
you guys pretty much have similar
answers uh so Yonce is 31 so
that makes where is Michael Jackson yeah
fiance is 31 bro Michael Jackson 45. so
not too bad yeah
um cench and Dave
they're gonna be yeah
yeah they're not even in the top 50 yeah
yeah
they're not even in the top 50. wait so
what's the score so everyone's got one
point which was T swizzy
um
I don't even know how to do this because
um it would have been it would be
Beyonce next 31 but then that's that's
both that's both of you and that's all
three of you yeah MJ is 45 though
oh you said M you did say MJ
yeah REM has to take it then wait so
what's the difference what's the only
one that we had different between RAM
and I and MJ you said Drake I don't know
yeah who's above yeah yeah so Drake yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Drake is
number six bro oh [__] yeah yeah yeah my
bad because I I crossed it out when he
wasn't in top five so yeah uh
oh actually
Scott because Alice has Drake and Yonce
yeah as well and so he has and Taylor
Swift and Taylor Swift and Taylor Swift
so it's three three okay so who you had
the weekend and by Buddy guys it's long
as long as lucky one because bad Buddy's
nine the weekend is tenth you were at
sentient Dave yeah yeah yeah
sorry bro sorry bro sorry bro you have
the top 10 in your top five all right
come on so that's ten that's ten six
three yeah
damn that was rough man that was rough I
was certain with that weekend shout it
was way off Ed Sheeran Ed Sheeran would
have been such a basic Billy eilish
that's so obvious
yeah guys let's take a real quick break
today we're here with a sponsor for your
bouncing bundle of joy and we're not
talking about a baby we're talking about
the baby makers that's right today's
show is brought to you by manscapes guys
but just like babies your man's delicate
little guys have sensitive skin and
deserve products that are not only skin
safe but made with safe ingredients
that's where manscape's Platinum package
comes in from razors to shower care this
package goes above the gold standard for
body hair so treat your beautiful boy to
the world's finest toys at manscape.com
and use our exclusive code
sng Sierra November golf for 20 off plus
free shipping let's get back to the
episode
all right REM de La Creme trash news for
today please sir let's go
so
um in this week's episode of America is
not a real place yeah
um have you man seen
oh
Marie Alabama River boat brawl yeah oh
my days I haven't actually seen the
whole thing I see Dolly dashes yes he
charged a high say let's go let's go
yeah it's happening
oh dear
nope
yeah who the hell is that yeah so I saw
from another a camera angle somebody
jumped to the Box off the boat to swim
to help my man yeah they're taking ages
what I do know about this brawl is
um apparently the man got a fruit hat in
here he is I think he works like I said
Works in around the area yeah he asked
one of them to move their boats yeah so
he he was the driver of this big boat
here apparently the Riverboat yeah right
and these two white Dawns were driving
those little oh yeah the ones little
dinghy boats yeah he had to be like move
move yeah yeah you can't just park your
boat here and they were like suck your
mom yeah yeah yeah so that's when he
came out like move your thing and now
again like sharp bro and that's when
yeah yeah I found it through Saturday
yeah yeah
murdered the Hat yeah I found it um all
right hit me several unidentified people
were taken into custody on Saturday
night after a massive brawl broke out in
the Montgomery Riverfront Park things
began to things began after several
white people uh was seen attacking a
black man over a boat dock space
according to Montgomery Police
Department report officers responded to
a disturbance at the 200 block of Coosa
Street around 7 PM MPD officials said
that there was a large group of people
fighting leading to several of them
being detained uh yeah that is from the
official link right
oh mad bro it's crazy but I mean that's
crazy as a story but what the trash news
is that what I was going to bring today
was that the actual responses and the
replies that have come out of this okay
okay not this like it's about the
British this brother was swimming
Michael Phelps
wow wow
names given to given to his young hero
black Aquaman
Michael B felt Captain Hook catfish
cause Kofi Kofi Kingfish Tyrone luck
21 tilapia
[Laughter]
Shaquille o'gill's fan that's funny
brooted me C-Murder and Evander home
oh my God Jesus Christ that's the most
joked thing I despair with the bat
signal for the Hat
literally was the bat signal actually
was that yeah so I the story itself was
just a horrible kind of like race walk
yeah yeah yeah bro black Twitter itself
yeah loves to just make
it's actually dread though that he
launched his head his hat like let's go
and no offense Dolly rocked his draw
twice in the process yeah he locked his
he launched his hat and said let's go
white bread sweat crack crack yeah yeah
it's embarrassing I saw
um I saw a re-up of I think the initial
guy that robbed the black guy
um it said he he um there was a tick
tock that showed a video of him like
blood didn't knows everything he's like
oh clearly this key can throw hands or
something like that so he showed a
little video of himself like just face
masks
bro yeah yeah well I did see this week
though I think it happened yesterday or
two days ago in central uh the Oxford
Street just a stampede of use just Robin
stuff Robin stuff one Tick Tock
orchestrated robbery bro yeah on Oxford
Street yeah people got arrested yeah I
just see youth scurrying out here tick
tocks yeah doing too much it's not this
is not the side of tick tock I see yeah
I just little little things here and
there but yeah like I can't I haven't
seen the true story about it but
something to do with like
there was such an orcas like I'm
planting on Oxford Street with just like
hundreds hundreds hundreds
now fans Hunters are blacks that's what
he was just black used Robin [__] on
Oxford Street robbing [__] and running
running yeah like 14 15 year olds yeah
bear 15 Rose bro summer holidays got
these men acting up yeah
um just doing a Madness on Oxford Street
is
jarring because I promise you if I was
just minding my business on Oxford
Street that day and just everyone teeth
and [__] and running
it's long bro it's long because I'm also
I'm not getting grips yeah yeah facts
facts facts and more getting grips with
you man I can tell you that for free
yeah
um but yeah it's it's Butters yeah Tick
Tock prank [__] is getting a bit mad out
of hand bro yeah out of hand anyway but
yeah that was that was good try to stay
for the cool all right uh you've got a
show recommendation for us I do have a
show recommendation for you guys so Remy
needs to pull up for me
um Paramount plus lioness what do you
mean power you're not paying for this
Paramount plus lioness you you will pay
for it no I'm saying since when do you
pay for Powerman plus only just the
other day for what
oh I have a recommendation I didn't I
saw the trailer and watched it you saw
the trailer for this and therefore I
have to pay the subscription fee
where big man it's a song
lioness is a show special op show Zoe
Saldana doesn't play oh I was wondering
how you you were spitting gamora's name
so quickly when I mentioned yeah she
doesn't play bro
they're under chick next to her is it
Leila what does that says
oh my God they they torture this woman
oh God not again they are not on a
different not like a burnt tank yeah
they torture this one yeah so um
backstories those are Donna she's a
special ops agent the chick next to her
laser I can't see her laser
um she's also a special ops I'm gonna
say I think that s is silent
I think her name's Layla yeah
[Laughter]
okay let's say Layla yeah she's also a
special ops agent who gets recruited
into um Zoe Saldana's team uh Dave on
the far right the white brother is Zoe
Saldana's man
um they've been married for God knows
how long they both have obviously
several lives he's a doctor or uh yeah
he's a doctor in a like a world pristine
hospital and there's a lot of in her
personal life there's a lot of um
um political topics because obviously
it's an interracial family and they've
got two use and when I say her person
they're both for their personal lives
are so separate from what the jobs that
they do because they haven't they have
this deal where
they don't tell each other what happens
at work but also they don't also lie to
each other and they um
um but they keep separating because
obviously as a doctor you can't tell
your wife about patient stuff yeah she's
special ops she can't tell her husband
[__] okay all he knows is that she's
away on job but he knows that but he
doesn't know as as um
but the whole thing the whole premise of
the show is about
um Layla being
um like thrown into the deep end to try
and catch a bigger fish for the special
ops group so she has to follow
um I can't remember her name but she's a
I think it's the Carla chick the color
chick in the in the picture I can't
remember my name in the show but she has
to like follow her and become befriend
her basically to find out what where her
husband is and where her
um because her husband's the main target
so they have to find out where he's
staying or where everything's going to
be so they can try like obviously
infiltrate and
obviously do the thing but the show
starts off with literally like a bang
with
um Zoe's showing her us showing
um Zoe's team in like obviously like a
Black Ops type of situation she's trying
to save someone and [__] just literally
just explodes and that was like the
first first scene and then it goes back
into the background of how um her and
Layla met and all of that stuff but in
terms of like the special ops the action
the grit it's 18 plus I'm gonna say it's
18 plus 18 plus oh really
episode two make you realize why I said
18 plus thank you okay tortured this
woman okay they torture okay cool I'm
I'm signing today how many just one
season it's one season so far there's
only four episodes so far it's a week by
week Sunday
yeah
that should be five episodes and just a
caveat four episodes and I've never seen
Morgan Freeman yet okay gang I'm not C
Morgan they got Michael Kelly brother he
was in a house of cards was it uh who am
I looking at Michael Kelly uh the board
oh he was a villain in that oh bro uh
yeah he was sick yeah he wanted it all
he did yeah they've got it's a very very
good car Paul Kidman she stays doing it
yeah it's a very good cast it's um it's
a strong strong show all right gang I
would definitely die I said I saw the
trailer and bought Paramount plus the
thing is I once I saw it was Zoe saldan
I just knew she's in a bag at the moment
yeah she is she's in her bag at the
moment so I knew it wouldn't it wouldn't
be disappointed I was not wrong
okay the first episode you'll be hooked
and with with uh Paramount plus they
don't [__] about with like adverts and
stuff once you press play the show
starts that's one thing yeah listen yeah
these streaming services that think they
can take my money and show me adverts
yeah they got gold they have got gold
they've got golden orders for Apple for
example there was only advertised Apple
shares yeah now TV do the same damn
thing and I'm like I see what you're
doing yeah just stop stop I'd pay this
for a reason
I give you my money for a reason you're
disrespecting me yeah and there's
nothing I can do about it who am I
complaining to yeah facts who am I
complaining to the one thing I would say
um about Paramount TV or Paramount plus
rather because I like comparing like the
different stream of service once I see
them
the one thing it doesn't have for now is
the skip intro which is Jared so if you
do so few dude it's literally Disney
plus and uh Netflix Netflix as far as
Amazon have skip intro do they really oh
yeah they do Amazon Amazon have it too
now doesn't now doesn't I'm not using
the jarring yeah bro
um Crunchyroll doesn't doesn't control
needs it yeah Crunchyroll has it no
maybe not on on maybe on a laptop maybe
but not on the it doesn't yes it does
because I literally skipped an intro of
Hell's Paradise this morning
yeah because I've got my skip by five
seconds down to a science yeah I've been
skipping the intro on Crunchyroll
recently yeah oh fair enough it must be
something recent then all right game man
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
recommendation definitely I'm gonna need
a reminder in a few weeks when it when
it Cooks a little bit more yeah yeah
um I'm I'm ready to jump into Jiu Jitsu
Castle now I mean it's like four four
five episodes I've not watched for the
past two weeks are you up to date yes
say less I've missed the last two all
right I've not watched anything I've
been letting it so yeah with bleach oh
yeah please juice juice yeah it is
you see when renji dropped Bots yeah
yeah
he was a [__] for Years bro Banker
every day bro
um but yeah yeah I'm gas for it all
right gang uh you've got an am I the
[__] for us I do am I the [__] for
getting upset that my wife told a trashy
College story
yesterday was hanging out with my wife
and Friends joking around and telling
stories my wife's friend Sarah asked me
has your wife ever told you about how
she made two guys have a UFC match my
wife was like oh my God shut up and they
go back and forth until I say I want to
hear the story my wife says it's so dumb
and I'm gonna hate it but I'm too
curious at this point someone says she
tells me about this
she Sighs and says she will
so my wife says basically I was at this
college party and these two guys were
hitting on me hard and like they were
kind again competitive and a little
aggressive towards each other
so I told them if they fought each other
one-on-one I would go home with the
winner oh her friends are dying laughing
and Sarah's dumb ass is saying don't
forget to tell them how you made them
fight in their underwear hahaha what the
[__] I was shocked I asked my wife if
she actually went through with this and
she's like you mean did I sleep with the
winner yes to be honest
she can see I'm stunned so she reminds
me so she reminds me I beg to hear it
later on at night when it's just the two
of us I tell her I tell her how
disappointed I am that um that was a
gross story and she shouldn't be
laughing about it or telling anybody she
reminds me that I wanted to hear it but
I thought it would be a normal crazy
College story not whatever the [__] that
was
you would buy it for half an hour but
she refuses to apologize so i s so I
decide to sleep in the guest room the
story was trashy I thought I deserved an
apology for hearing it they shouldn't be
a joking about it am I the [__] or is
my wife oh that I like that one you know
yeah I really like that one that was a
bit different you recoupled okay so
recap there are party yeah who is sorry
who is Sarah Sarah is one of the the
wife's Brethren just one of the wise
Brothers one of the wise Brothers I'm
assuming they went to college together
okay cool
um so we're at a party Sarah's we're all
giggling and Sarah's like oh did she
ever tell you about the UFC fight and
I'm like nah nah what's that what's that
I know myself you don't need to hear it
it's a stupid cult story I'm like UFC
fighter what do you mean what do you
mean
um and she's like
um it's a techie one
because then obviously yeah cool she
tells the story
and I'm picturing being homeboy here in
my wife say that not only did she get
you guys to fight for her affection she
actually did bang the winner
that's
brazy
I can't hear stuff like that because I
didn't marry that yeah yeah whatever
that is is not my wife which means you
bang the winner with his face all much
that's scary stuff I I already know the
feeling in my chest yeah as um as soon
as as soon as she says about all these
two guys are hitting to me so I told
them if they fought each other yeah
um I would see as soon as I heard her
say I would sleep with the winner my
face would drop
same my face will drop
um and I don't want to hear anymore
and then for me to like did you actually
bang it up but obviously we're in a
public setting
so I can't say what I want to say
because what I want to say is stop stop
[__] talking right now yeah I I don't
want to hear the rest of this story bro
yeah but yeah I'm dead
it's so funny yeah yeah eating kind of
pace nah bro
um
but
one thing I will say is like
if you're gonna be in a relationship
first of all
Sarah can shut up facts there's no way
in hell one of you man will be dumb
enough to obey out a story like that to
my wife yep yep yep there needs to be
boundaries boundaries and if you were
like dumb enough to slip up there needs
to be code words from like 86 this
conversation now immediately immediately
immediately yeah
and then same thing with spouses like
obviously everyone's got a past yeah you
need to be able to have the thing and be
like babe no like you don't want to hear
the story facts understand me when I'm
telling you you don't want to hear the
story and that needs to be established
clearly they don't have that established
um but but that wouldn't wouldn't that
entice you more to want to hear the
story yes but then I can't beat her
about it um yeah true true that's what
I'm saying like he yeah it granted the
paranoia yeah the paranoid would eat me
alive yeah I'd want to hear the story
yeah but now it's at my own risk now I
can't be once once you've told me the
story now I have to charge all my
emotions
finger
so question is is she the [__] is he
she's not the [__] I completely agree
she's not the [__] she told the story
she was pressured to tell facts she
didn't want to tell it she didn't bring
it up facts she just had to tell it and
Sarah's even added in yeah underwear
bits don't forget to remind him they
fought in their underwear
blogs I would sweep her feet
it's UFC all over again yeah facts get
in your underwear we're gonna scrap but
the whole
I okay one thing I will say
one thing I will say
is
if you love me we've said it many times
before you have to lie to me you have to
lie to me if I tell if I ask you plain
and simple did you [__] the winner look
me in my face and say obviously not no
of course not bad of course not what do
you mean what I watched two guys beat
the [__] out of it and then I just took
some Bruce home guy and bagged him he
must be mad come on that's not me come
on man you know me what do you think and
Sarah bear get the hint of if imagine
she does this you're like what yes you
did what what are you all about why are
you lying
smack that's that is our friendship done
yes
oh yeah it has to be because that's
boundaries you can't yeah I would say
in that moment she's not an [__] for
it but yeah play play the game properly
yeah let me love you facts let me be the
one too you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah Mario yeah
because I can't hear stuff like that
facts I cannot hear that you bang the
guy that you made fist fight another guy
yeah that's that's the craziest stuff
it's Bonkers yeah he's a um
yeah he's a bit of a [__] who needs to
charge it he does need to charge it and
um Sarah or any bridge and that decides
to do that to me is not a Brethren bro
that's it's that just can't run I would
never throw you man on the bus like that
it just can't run in a public scene
never ever throw him out of the boss
like that you man mustard you must be on
something yeah so flagrant you're on
stuff bro you'd see my face immediately
hang on
let me get a character
I'm not even paying attention to You My
Bae is here in your Syria all right go
and go oh don't forget to tell her about
you guys we're in the underwear no start
from scratch start from scratch yeah
yeah because I'm not letting you get to
underwear okay yeah yeah it's not from
scratch I'm not letting you get that far
yes uh what's her name forget her name
guys did your wife ever tell you the
story about her making to you guys fight
like UFC Style
no I never told that story still are you
sure
you sure you never told him you sure you
never told me
you sure you never told me yeah you've
never told him
I swear maybe I should tell it you
reckon maybe I should tell it basically
imagine if I'm old I'm looking at your
chain thinking
I hope your head comes with it
should I tell it
yeah there's you don't understand code
words fail you don't understand we don't
have a friendship because you must
understand the position you're putting
me in bro asked I'll tell you charges
now yes it's it's that's crazy man
that's absolutely crazy but yeah I
personally don't think she's the [__]
but I also think I agree like you said I
would definitely lie to his face in
front of everyone that's in the
surrounding just to save face yeah yeah
and then if it gets brought up again I
might tell him or her but I just don't I
don't think I just don't think bringing
up in the first place oh bro Sarah and
the whole party but yeah 100 love of my
life if I ask you did you seriously bang
the guy
I don't think to be honest yeah I did
you asked why you asked trying to be
honest with you babe no you didn't be
honest you asked me for the truth I
don't lie to you you see you don't
literally learn I'm it's not it's not my
bag
I'm only learning what your bag is now
yeah but everyone's got a passport
everyone's got a past
because that's disgusting everyone's got
a past that the crazy obviously
I don't care what anyone says here
because I first of all I don't ask so I
don't want to hear but like people love
to pretend that like oh maturity
maturity when no one likes hearing about
your partner's past bro no one likes
hearing about it like to my knowledge
every girlfriend I'm with has been a
virgin like I don't need to know your
past my bro yeah bro in fact I don't
need to what's yeah what's I gonna do
for me it's irrelevant to us what's
gonna do for me 100 but yeah it's it's
nuts bro yeah that's that's friendship
done oh yeah I can't see you at the next
function yeah bro I can't because you're
a little you're a little Chatty Cathy
bro you don't know how to you don't know
where the boundaries are yeah but yeah
anyway I've got a little thread to
finish this off yeah yeah I've entitled
it racist thread so here we go
I think I know this yeah I know exactly
what this thread is and I saved it it's
hilarious bro it's hilarious right
you're sweet in me so Tyler the thread
have you ever had a race six experience
that was funny though
bro let me let me well we'll go back to
back yeah I want to go back to back yeah
let me see if I can let me find on mine
was that a Taco Bell slash KFC combo
spot years ago first of all brazy
was looking at the Taco Bell side of the
menu trying to figure out what to order
this little white cashier pointed to the
KFC KFC menu and said the chickens on
this side
no
the chickens on this side that's crazy
that's crazy that's crazy bro you make
minimum wage
why are you risking your life like this
Oh my days I remember working at Target
and some old man thought some [__] was
on sale so when the price came up he was
like what you talking about Willis
oh [__] was hella racist but funny
yeah what'd you talk about with it
the starring oh that's so funny
right
in high school I got sat next to this
Asian kid and in my head I was like I
wonder what Asian he is if I don't ask
because uh what if he thinks that's rude
and the first question he asked me was
so what part of Mexico are your parents
from my parents are from East L.A I saw
that one wow yeah una reverse first
question yeah what part of Mexico are
they from that's
yeah I can't even you don't know
anything about me you know anything
about me I'll be so spun ask me my name
I'll be so smart that's crazy
Jesus Christ I lived in West Virginia
during High School I was at football
practice at a newer school and most of
my teammates were white my coach pulls
me to the side mid practice and says
damn where are the brothers at
reply to that so this is hilarious the
coach was sick of the lack of talent
jokes practice
get on my face man also where are they
at Fox where are they be around here
yeah had a friend in elementary school
in Brackets white of course every time I
spent the night with get KFC it got to a
point where I got tired of it and asked
why do we why do you always eat KFC he
looked at me with the straightest face
and said we only eat that when you're
here
bro
why do y'all even always eat KFC mine
said we only eat that when you're here
what
bro
what bro wrong like I say he's back at
me [__] yeah
wow you only eat that when you're here
wow my mom's trying to accommodate wow
wow a lie yeah say less that's mad and
they don't do pigs feet round here bro
so it has to be KFC
ask me why are black people so good at
Mortal Kombat
[Laughter]
oh my taste bro that's funny
all right my last one yeah
this one's weird me
I was having a bad hair day yeah so I
covered it with a scarf someone on the
bus thinking it was a hijab screamed
obscenities at me and snatched it off
with the reveal of my half done box
braids and visible shock he then said oh
and then tried to put the scarf back on
me
after violating me you're trying to
violate me I said oh [__] oh damn I
thought this was a different yeah I
thought it's been a different kind of
race racist I lied my bad my bad they're
trying to put it back it reminds me
I should have fixed the box that's crazy
oh my goodness a different type of race
I [__] up and was the wrong type of
racist
um wow so this one is they're in a bus
random white lady
um I like your daughter's hair I like
your daughter's hair me thank you her
mum made it random white lady nice I
love the ribbons too
three minutes later white lady starts
humming CK love
[Music]
just for no reason on the bus
just for no reason
jarring bro
Oh my days yeah you um did you see oh
there was a tick tock I saw a little
while ago
this chick [__]
up bro okay there's a guy like asking
um I know exactly what you say uh one
black guy two white yeah one black guy
two white girls said if you could wake
up as any other race what would it be
yeah yeah and one one he turns on one
chicken she was like
well we're the superior race so why
would I want to wake up and then you
have a race and she was like she tried
to double move
[Applause]
along the lines of like you might just
go through hard you might have gone but
she'll obviously pointing to the black
guy and he's like double down she just
had to walk away bro she had to walk I
had to walk away yeah brazy crazy crazy
with a superior race so why would I so
why would I want to be anyone else why
are you asking me dumb questions
white obviously yeah the answer is white
the next race I would wake up as is
white it's white and then raise after
that it's white
oh ask me dumb questions
that's hilarious bro right guys anyway
thank you for jumping with us today this
has been paying as always uh if you want
to catch a little bit more of SMG head
on over to patreon.com
and uh as always guys catch you next
week
[Music]
foreign